>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Tomoko Steen: Hi, good morning.
I'm Tomoko Steen here at
the Science and Technology
and Business Divisions
Library of Congress.
I'm a Research Specialist
in Specialized in Science.
In fact, today's speaker
is a Professor of Business.
So, in fact the business expert
in my division should have been
introduced this excellent speaker,
but I happened to get
to know him and so lucky
to learn a lot about his research.
So, today's speaker Professor
Ketcham is the professor
at the University of Houston.
And he's kind enough to come
and share his current
research on the space ethics.
A lot of people ask me you
know, what space ethics is,
I think you have to ask him.
And he has a PhD from the
University of Texas at Austin
and he is also CPCU, I'm
not an expert in Business,
so I'm not familiar with it,
but he is chartered property
casualty underwriter, also.
And that is -- he's a
property casualty insurance
and risk management expert.
So, a very interesting
you know, point of view.
Looking at space topics from
the business point of view.
And we -- you know
facing a commercialization
and the space exploration has
been always very much a concern
for the two scientists I actually
posted a new, just available
and Carl Sagan, but now
it's commercialization --
it's another concern
and it's exciting
and very interesting
things to think about.
And today's topic is space ethics.
So before further ado, please
join me to welcome our speaker.
[ Applause ]
>> Christopher Ketcham: Thank
you Dr. Steen, thank you Library
of Congress and thank all
of you for coming here.
Now as a risk management
guy people accuse us
of wearing both belts
and suspenders.
But, what we're talking
about is the ultimate risk
and that of course, is in space.
Space, the final frontier.
These are the voyages
-- oh, no, no, no.
No, let's go back a little bit
farther than Star Trek and see
where we began in the space race.
Now what I want to do is I'm going
to take you back at the triangle --
I have to hit the triangle,
the page up button, right?
Okay. I'm going to take
you back just be --
just months before President
Kennedy announced his vision
of putting a man on the moon
before the decade was out.
Outgoing President Eisenhower
gave his farewell address.
In it he said, "The prospect of
domination of the nation's scholars
by federal employment, project
allocations and the power
of money is ever present.
And is gravely to be regarded.
Yet in holding scientific
research and discovery and respect,
as we should, we must also be alert
to the equal and opposite danger
that public policy could
itself become the captive
of a scientific technological
elite".
The military industrial complex
has dominated the space program
since its beginning.
Even before Sputnik the idea of
weaponizing space with missiles
and satellites has been the
centerpiece of government policy.
Industry has elbowed its way
into the fray capitalizing
on communications, GPS and
other military advances
to improve communication, weather
forecasting and the lives of people
and business around the world.
Like any effort begun in war was the
space race technology finds its way
into the hands of people who
are not associated with war.
As unfortunate that war is the
genesis of such improvements,
but we as a species seem not
able to extract ourselves
from conflict and combat.
Now I am going to ask you to
channel Carl Sagan for a minute.
And think what was his famous word?
Billions. So, I want you to think
in billions and even trillions now,
because what people are
saying is they're getting,
what Green Span might have
called irrational exuberance
over the prospect of doing
really great things in space.
"The National Space Society
claims it's rationale
for promoting space settlement is
a survival of the human species",
even going that far
we're looking at.
"The Space Frontier Group, a
California-based advocacy group
with a similar vision,
claims it is dedicated
to opening the Space Frontier
to human settlement as
rapidly as possible".
Billions. Think billions.
Now in 2008 Jacques Arnold and
Andre Gabuv declared ethics is
in some sense the frontier
in space exploration.
The frontier of exploration is being
pushed outward at a rapid pace,
bringing the need for
complex ethical analysis
to the floor today, and
not into the future.
We're embarking upon a new use
for space and that is peace.
Physicists and astronomers
increasingly use space
to improve our understanding
of the universe and its forces.
We have discovered
water, precious minerals,
rare earth elements
on celestial objects.
We scan the Heavens for alternative
earths and goldilocks zones;
we're conditions for
life might be present.
We gaze longingly at
Mars for opportunities
to support a separate colony
for life outside of the earth.
Companies like planetary resources
have informed mine asteroids,
once the technology
becomes available to do so.
Moon express plans on
mining rare earth element,
helium three on the moon
within the next few years.
Enigmatic India, with its
intractable poverty has
since the 1960's built a
successful space operation that's
very economical.
And will undoubtedly
attract many who want to get
to space very inexpensively.
>> Space has been made available
for humanity; however we must face
and overcome considerable
hurdles to do so.
As Eisenhower warned us we are
still primarily thinking technology
in the space race.
It is now we must consider,
begin to consider the human,
and not just the long term
survival ability of a Mars lander.
But the sociology and
ecology of space colonies
and its companion the
macro economics
of space industry and commerce.
Here's why we must begin now.
Successful international space
station re-supplier space X is
working on a rocket capable
of holding 100 passengers
on a long trip in order
to place their goal
of one million persons on Mars.
Mars One, from the Netherlands
wants to send a colony to Mars
on a one way ticket to be
funded by a Truman like show,
reality television series
about the colonists.
Very interesting prospect.
Space X warns that the risk of death
for these new age astronauts
will be high.
Why? Colonists will be ordinary
humans, not the astronauts
that weave the logic
driven, risk calculating,
cool under fire astronauts that
we've been used to in the past.
>> While the National Space
Society has been discussing space
settlements since the
mid-1970's we remain today
like Lewis and Clark and Sacagawea.
Who on the urging of
President Jefferson set
out into the wilderness of the
Louisiana Purchases to see what use
of the New Republic could
make of all this wilderness.
Of course, we did make
use of the land
and have prospered and
grown because of it.
We also did some nasty things
to the indigenous inhabitants,
both human and animal.
The wilderness of space is
our next place of exploration;
however distance radiation, vacuum,
cold and time itself far exceed the
considerable obstacles Lewis, Clark,
Sacagawea and others endured
on their 19th century
voyage of discovery.
Star Wars and Star Trek both
present space as a place of war.
Where they're armed with the
force of photon, torpedoes,
military organizations, pit right
against mite through federation
or empires with efforts towards
diplomacy, but diplomacy backed
up with weapons, we
can only imagine.
Little mention is made of
the millions of people who go
through their lives
with quiet desperation
and the frontier outpost exposed
to adverse weather, hostile forces,
corruption and bandits, just
like our own pioneers endured
furring the 19th century.
We read the Dystopian
novels like Red Rising
about the Martian mining community
that becomes a caste system complete
with its disposable untouchables.
These fictional accounts
explore not only the fictional--
explore not only fictional
human proclivities
to put prophets before
people and far outposts
where industrialists create new
mining communities reminiscent
of those company towns, so prevalent
in the early industrialization
of this country and Europe.
When we build space colonies we
will bring our own human issues,
frailties and problems with us.
Space gives us an opportunity
to rethink our own propensity
towards war and hadjemite.
However our nascent efforts
foretell an [Inaudible] beginning.
We continue to weaponize space.
We conduct science and
business alongside spy
and weaponize satellites.
Like the rivers of the 1960's we
have riddled near earth space lanes
with space junk is becoming
a critical navigation hazard.
Even as we pursue space productivity
we are confined to a little world
of 25,000 miles circumference,
which we can use --
continue to use with
considerable abandon.
Space is huge, measured in
light years, not kilometers.
We can rationalize that we
should litter some place
but there are many others that
are pristine and we can go there.
We can solve problems of
over population, refugees,
poverty by establishing kindliness
on Mars, who will take our tired,
poor and hungry masses
learning to breathe free.
Breathe is the first operative word.
The second is radiation.
The third gravity.
A third of our own.
We may have to live
underground like moles on Mars
because the planet
has no magnetic field
to deflect the sun's radiation.
For the foreseeable future
we must important everything,
even water if we can't
distill whatever water
that is near the surface,
which is likely even
to be more salty than the Dead Sea.
I suggest that before we go too far
in conquering space using some
same brute force we've used
on our own planet in its
orbit, that we pause and begin
to understand both the implications
and opportunities that
space provides.
In other words we need to consider
what we might become an ethics
of space, including how we
govern and police ourselves
as we begin the human
occupation of the cosmos.
Any ethics we have of space
necessarily will involve societal,
organizational and
business implications.
We went to the moon to
prove military superiority.
We must know think beyond pure
science, weapons and begin
to reason like business persons.
But within an I told you,
reasonable, ethical foundation
as a restraint against
undo exploitation
of people or celestial bodies.
Economics will certainly
be an early challenge
of deep space once we figure out how
to thrive outside of our own planet.
Regardless of the persistence outcry
against regulation, we let business
and comments run without significant
hindrance, this is a good thing
because it produces competition,
innovation and wealth.
On earth we can inspect
manufacturing facilities, products
and monitor how people
are treated by industry.
How long will it take and how much
will it cost to send an inspector
to human outposts 10
million miles away?
What do the patrol vessels that will
stop piracy, looting and maleficent;
where are our aircraft
carriers in the universe?
Well commercial vessels
need to be like Star Wars
and the Millennial Falcon
bristling with guns.
Let Captain Han Solo
operate like a 19th century,
18th or 19th century pirate
and the rich space lanes
of the asteroid belt.
Are we ready for a
Klondike Gold Rush
where everyone is for
himself or herself?
Are we ready for Bad Bart,
hanging judges and cattle wars
in the prairie outposts of space?
Planetary resources that would
be space miners have identified
asteroids consisting of near
pure platinum, each worth as much
as get this, a trillion
dollars or more if mined
and brought back to earth.
Will we let miners like we did
in the Klondike simply rush
towards these celestial objects
because they have the will
and the finances to do so?
The first will be like robot
miners and space dump trucks
that will bring ore
back to the earth
or even facilities of
space for processing.
How much is it going to cost to
bring this stuff back down to earth?
We as yet don't know.
This was the case in the
Klondike and other gold rushes.
This platinum rush will
benefit the first miners most.
After we saturate the earth with
more platinum than we can use,
even as we create markets
for platinum ware,
hubcaps and bathroom faucets.
The cost of mine asteroids
will become prohibitive
when the market crashes.
Mining the asteroid belt takes
such onus to earth's environment,
perhaps even more so than the
gold rush and other mines have.
Errant equipment, disasters and
other accidents can alter the orbit
of space objects, perhaps
even sending one or more
on a trajectory towards earth.
How will we regulate space mining?
Just as important, who
will own the asteroids?
In 2015 President Obama signed the
HR2262 which permits US citizens
to own asteroid resources
both here and in space.
When we divvy up the asteroid belt
like the colonial powers of the 18th
and 19th century, or we will
declare the asteroid belt
as we have declared the open
sea, the heritage of humanity.
And subject to no individual
sovereign.
Well least asteroids
feels like we do
to oil drilling rights,
for how long?
Will we create depletion
deductions and taxes
as we whittle away space rock
and return it to the earth,
the moon or mars for processing?
Who will be tasked with enforcing
the asteroid that we need to -
we actually need to create?
The UN? The UN has been useful
dealing with many earthly issues
and has debated in many countries
have signed the space treaties
and declarations.
Is the UN really the right
place for space governance?
This is important concern
because there are many questions
about governance in space.
One looming one is who will
police incredibly vast space lanes
against piracy, space junk and
other navigation issues or step
up when interplanetary mining dump
trucks are hijacked and ransomed
or sold on the black market?
We will send earthly
microbes into empty space.
The planets, their moons
and other celestial bodies.
We've already done so despite
the heroic efforts of NASA -
on NASA's office of planetary
protection and the statements
by COSPR, Committee on
Space Research at the UN,
scientists who are committed
to microbe free landers.
We have diligent cleanliness,
standards for orbiters and landers.
The operatal standards cannot
prevent some spores and bacteria
from hitching a ride to the moon,
mars or any other body we have
visited or intend to visit.
We brought life to Mars.
We don't know yet whether we'll
be reanimated or reanimate itself.
But it's on our rovers.
It just takes one bacteria
to find a niche and divide.
That's the issue we have
to deal with, with life.
Remember the old saw
from Jurassic Park?
Life finds way.
When we land the first human
with a gut full of bacteria,
skin crawling with tiny mites,
viruses and other critters,
steps outside the air lock we bring
life to the place where we step.
Any breach in the air suite
or hole will light the scape.
Some life might take in
places in the wild or inside
in enclosed colonies and begin to
evolve separate from the earth.
We know for example that the
international space station is
creating its own ecology.
Microbes are evolving to thrive
in the conditions present
at the station and the
migration of people in and out.
When we establish a Martian colony
and it must become more
or less self-sufficient.
What schemes of ecology
are we going to establish
to maintain a viable system
of life for the long term?
What mix plants and animals?
How will we deal with the evolution
or normal cycles or even accidents
that threaten the colonial
ecosystems we likely will need
to maintain for our
own existence on Mars?
Later we may want to
[Inaudible] Mars
if we could ever figure
that one out.
But in either case we're still
create a separate evolving world
where microbes that
once evolved only
on earth will evolve
independently on Mars.
Travel back and forth will create
opportunities for invasive species,
insects and others to wreak havoc
on other celestial bodies
and even earth itself.
Humans have little regard for inner
generational justice beyond the next
two generations comprising
children and grandchildren.
Our lives only extend that
far and to think beyond one -
what's become a clouded
about the uncertainty,
then it isn't our problem.
Business horizons are often
90 days or at most a year.
We rationalize and say "Well
our grandparents had to deal
with it, let them deal with it".
Our own death is a finality we
cannot seem to think beyond.
What I'm asking is that we think
beyond the next two generations
and at least begin a dialogue on the
major issues that we, as a species
and even life itself will be
facing over the countless millions
of generations into the future.
I'm not asking us to predict
the state of humanity, the world
and our ventures in space
a billion years from now.
What I'm asking is that we establish
a line of dialogue for as many
of the issues of space and
space ethics we can envision
that we will likely encounter.
We are entering a new phase
which I call the cosmo scene.
We call it the Anthropocene
is the term used by many
to describe humans, humanities
impact on the earth ecology.
The dinosaurs had their
own scene, we have ours.
The cosmo scene asks what impact
we're going to have on space,
first space in our solar system
which is vast enough, and then next,
the Milky Way Galaxy that
is dissonance unimaginable.
If we can better phrase the
basic questions we will need
to continually address, I suggest we
will embark upon a path towards an
inter-generational ethics of space
for which we will eventually
look back
and say this is much crowning
achievement as a theory
of relativity, the first man moon
mission and the idea of democracy.
The independent science center
committee on space research,
COSPR and our own NASA
are good places to begin.
But we must ad, and Dr. Steen knows
this, economist, business persons,
financial analysis, financiers,
social psychologists, sociologists
and biologists in addition to
doctors, engineers and physicists.
We want to create not only
an economic engine of space
but also a viable ecological and
sociological colonization system
in places hostile to
humanity and life itself.
There's not enough time in
this forum to discuss each
of the questions associated with
commerce, travel, habitation,
alien life and other
topics we need to explore.
We need more forums like this one
where such questions
can be developed
and debated before we begin the
process of living and working
in space on another
celestial bodies in earnest.
I suggest we must do this
before those who want
to exploit the heavens set
problematic precedence's
that may be difficult to overcome.
I'll spend the rest of
this time I have with you
to begin the discussion
of one issue in more depth
and that is human space governance.
And there's not been a
lot of attention on this.
Governance of human space
travel to this point has been
in the command control
style of the military.
This is expected to
continue on the space station
and probably even the
first lander on mars.
Science and military
were together not only
to design scientific protocol but
to produce the discipline and chain
of command in the limited
space of the space station
or future exploratory landings.
Astronauts have been like Seal
teams, they work together,
they know how to solve
problems and everything else.
Look at the good, bad and the ugly
in our world; our colonies are going
to contain all sites
of - types of persons
and attitudes, we'll need jails.
We'll need drug and alcohol
clinics, we'll need suicide watches.
The scope and size of things
that will change once industry
and government begin permanent
colonization endeavors.
There are a number of possible
governance models I would
like to explore with
you a little bit today.
These are not all of them by
any means, but they're a taste
of what we might be up against.
One we can call the off shore
drilling platform model.
This will be a commercial
venture where workers are employed
by specific business or government
enterprise to work full time
for a period of time at a site.
For example, at an
asteroid mining operation.
While we have employment
rules for US companies
on employment treatment, pay,
safety and other requirements
we do not have a workable system
for other worlds at this point.
Granted we have five space treaties
covering governing to some extent,
space exploration, near earth orbit,
rescue liability equipment
regulation, registration
and a treaty to make
space a peaceful region.
None of these has really
been tested;
none includes governance
to any real extent.
Disease, conditions of
space, force measure,
lack of transparency are all issues
where enforceability from earth
or even other outposts
may be challenging.
Distance and time also
complicates worker only outposts.
Workers maybe required to work for
years or even decades without relief
because the cost to
transport them to
and from work will be prohibitive.
With present equipment capabilities
a round trip journey to mars will be
like a sea voyage around the
world in Magellan's time, long,
stressful and quite often boring.
Magellan could stop and
replenish his stuff on islands.
We can't even do that
as we go to Mars.
We can expect troubles, fights,
medical emergency, insurrections,
suicide and any other
manner of irregularities
when people are confined
in restricted place
with the same persons for
month or years on end.
Can you just imagine hearing
this every day for a year?
Are we there yet?
And can you play the
license plate game in space?
No. Lots of video games and
people bouncing off walls.
The lack of social structure in
the off shore model compounds us.
There may be no spouses, children
and life outside the
work environment.
We'll likely find that the off
short oil platform model is not
sustainable ultimately because of
the time and challenges of space
for anything other than our moon.
Another model is what we
call the expect community.
This is where business
ships the workers
and their families to
remote work outposts.
This will become a more
or less permanent outposts
where families live, work,
socialize and go to school.
The expect community is really the
model for the old company town.
The question of governance
looms large here as it did
in the company towns of old.
The employers, the
community administrator,
the source of commerce,
the owner of property
and the purveyor of justice.
There will be limited
power of the community
to overcome oppressive
tactics by the business itself.
One cannot challenge
the work conditions
on the threat of being sacked.
What if one is sacked?
Okay we're going to send
you home in three decades,
what do you do between now and then?
This one may be touted as being
fair, equitable and wonderful
from the shiny pamphlets of
employers who want you to go there.
All I remember is the food
pickers from the Grapes of Wrath.
Shiny posters, great work,
great pay, neither one happened.
A third approach has a
number of different options.
All are based upon a pioneer model.
Recall that when we decided
to populate the prairies
in the 19th century
we offered free land.
In the space pioneer model
we probably will have
to offer the equivalent
of the sod house.
The containment vessel essential
for life at a remote outpost.
People will still arrive as
settlers rather than squat
and improve the land as were the
requirements don't own the land
during pioneer days.
Persons will be picked based
on their skills required
to sustain the outpost.
You've got to have a certain amount
of doctors, you need a lawyer,
you need biologists,
you need farmers,
you need a little of everything.
You need sanitation experts, you
need water, people, everything.
And a strong governance
approach, the local colony legally
and constitutionally is
attached to earthly governments.
This form of governance early on
will look like the current command
and control ventures but
will need to involve checks
and balances not unlike what
is available in the US today.
And this time hype of outposts
there will be the need to be
of all things we find and
communities or more, governments,
jobs, entertainment,
education, medical care
and justice will need to be there.
The beginning colony will
like have as its primary goal
to become self-sufficient
and self-sustaining.
This likely will require regular
supply missions from earth
to replace medicines and machinery
not be possible to produce
at the earliest outposts.
Early outposts may be
run almost like communes
where there will be little need for
capitalist economy, just survival.
Likely these colonies will be
expensive to establish and operate.
Who is going to continue
to pay for them
when they don't necessarily turn
a profit for how many decades
or hundreds of years perhaps?
An alternative to same
model we might call pioneer
condominium community.
In this form of governance the
colonists invest their own money
in the colony and pay off
creditors, which might be government
or industry at the very beginning.
Eventually such colonists will own
a piece of the colony and can sell
or dispose of it per
colony regulations.
We must also worry that the
billionaires will buy up units
and turn tenants into sharecroppers.
And another variation
of condominium,
pioneer condominium model,
the government subsidizes
the entire colony.
The colonies are then winged off the
subsidies, sort of like a mortgage
over time as it begins
to produce surplus goods
which can be exchanged
for earthly goods.
Individuals may then be
deed a title much the same
as the pioneers, our
pioneer ancestors.
What if they cannot produce
enough to eliminate the subsidy?
What happens then?
We don't have any provisions
for this?
Likely you can imagine
other organizations systems,
the pioneer form of organizations
more likely to be feasible
on a large celestial body
such as the moon or mars
in a large scale operation.
Colonies may be established next
to or near industrial operations
such as mine or manufacturing
facilities, some workers will be
in the factories or mine and
some will be doing other jobs,
producing food, recycling
waste and water,
governing policy, education
and justice.
In any of the scenarios the question
of independence and what that means.
All colonies will have
measures of independence just
like earthly pioneers;
however we know
that our own revolution
was fought in part
because of taxation
without representation.
Earth, what services are
you really providing us now
that we're pretty much
operating on our own?
How come we have to
pay all these taxes?
Distance and time will spread
earthly resources thin,
insurrections, revolts, mutinies,
takeovers and despites could occur
and become entrenched before
a policing vessel can arrive
at the colony.
In a weak earth governance approach,
colonies may also become separate
countries which means the need
for a galactic organization
that governs interspatial
commerce, defense and immigration.
Enforcement to rein in rogue
colonies presents other
humanitarian issues.
Penetration weapons in a confined
colony that's about as thick
as a tin can will surely
be disastrous.
Then of course no matter
what system of governance,
these will be pioneer outposts.
It's not likely the medical care
will approach that on earth,
mortality rates are
likely to be higher.
Psychological issues associated
with depression, phobias, anxieties,
suicide will likely require a
different approach to psychiatry
and close environment outpost.
Think submarines, especially
nuclear submarines that are
out for a very long period of time
because they don't have to refuel.
They can make their own water.
They can recycle the air.
However we've seen before where the
pioneers those are left the East
Coast to settle in the plains were
a hearty bunch, who sought relief
from crowded cities,
farming communities
where there was land too
expensive for the poor to purchase.
With atmospheric challenges before
any [Inaudible] occurs you can't
spread out, you're
stuck in a small space.
You can't get those 40 acres
out there and that mule
because there are no more 40
acres, everybody has their own.
So what becomes of earth in this new
planet, inter-planetary space model?
With growing population on that, any
persons who can't see the value of -
can see the value of
migrating to a space outpost
because they have no
opportunities here.
As production becomes more
automated and we enter in the era
of driverless cars, store-less
purchasing, what would people do
with their lives without jobs?
Likely in the US we are probably
- that's not in our blood
to give someone a sustainable
living wage for not working,
even if they can't get a job because
they don't have the proper education
to do what the new jobs demand.
Will space colonies be places where
these workers will go to find work?
No matter what form of outpost
we envision or ever build,
early efforts are likely to
produce economic equations
that will first rely
on heavily on subsidies
or large debt to entrepreneurs.
We do not yet have an economic
model in space that accounts
for the extraordinary cost of
travel in existence and the pursuit
of profits from productivity.
We may see the early - the
asteroid farmers make fortunes,
the law of supply and
demand on precious metals
and other commodities will likely
make these remote operations less
and less profitable until there
is a large enough space economy
to support that kind of activity.
We require a better understanding
just of what economic engines
of space will be out there and how
will they operate, and what forms
of social organization and
governance that will work in space?
Remember space is going to be a
lot different than here, confined,
minimal resources,
not huge environment.
Trashing the one Fichus Tree might
earn you a place not just in hell
but somewhere else entirely.
We must factor in transportation,
operating in existence cost
and space compared to earth.
We might discover that the economics
of space does not require including
earthy in a viable two way -
as a viable two way trading
partner except for select products
or commodities that cannot
yet be made in space.
Industry and persons on earth
probably can supply themselves
better than we can from space.
The cost to live from the earth,
in necessary goods for space,
for space colonies likely will
continue to be prohibitive.
Further isolating the
earth from space trade.
Presuming low cost robotic vessels,
the expense to do the same may
be less from our moon to mars
or through the asteroid belt
because all experience
less gravity than earth.
I suggest that there is a
distinct possibility that trade
between space parties might become
independent from earth in many ways,
including raw materials
such as ores for smelters
and manufacturing facilities,
seas and frozen food trade,
medicines and the like.
Persons who become
accustomed to or are born
in lower gravity may not
be able to visit earth,
let alone face off earthly diseases.
Education might also become a
commodity as candidates compete
for entry into mars as
elite Olympus University.
Finally, what about democracy?
It depends on how much
return and control
with the billionaire Elon Musk and
others want from their investment.
How beholden will space colonists
and travelers be to
space entrepreneurs.
Will they install their
governors and administrators
as the European monarchies did
when they established colonies?
These are all questions that must
be asked before the ships begin
to launch.
Which form of governance or
economics am I advocating?
I'm not advocating anything because
we don't have all the answers yet.
As a matter of fact we
have very few answers.
But what I'm asking is that we
begin today to ask questions
and put the question of governance,
social organization and justice
in the forefront of any long term
discussions of venture, of commerce,
or commercialization
outside of earth's orbit.
Thank you.
I look forward to your questions.
[ Applause ]
>> Tomoko Sheen: Any questions?
>> You talked a lot about
history and some of the things
that manifest destiny [Inaudible]
Blade Runner was a movie
that was made in 1982 talking
about a couple years from now
and that deals with
the concept of slavery
and it's laboring [Inaudible]
to society [Inaudible].
I'm curious, we have a lot
of problems here today.
We have slavery still
here today in some forms.
What's your thoughts
before we go anywhere,
solving a lot of the
issues we still have here
and maybe I think this is good
because it gives us balance
and comparison to say what if we
get to mars and we need to have
in place, as we know
it from history or now.
But what do we need to solve
now before we get to mars.
What are your thoughts
on that perspective?
>> Christopher Ketcham: So the
question is what do we need
to solve now and specifically
one of the questions
that was asked was
about slavery itself.
And Red Rising specifically
talks about issues
of businesses employing
slaves in the deep mines.
They did all the work while the
people, the golds on the top,
the reds were at the bottom,
the golds were at the top.
The golds basically were
like the gods of old.
They basically pranced around,
did all sorts of things.
They were the intellectual
bunch and the people
down in the bottom were the brawn.
My suggestion is not
necessarily that we're looking
for a Utopian world outside, but
we can start clean if we want to.
Meaning that if we know that there
are things that are difficult here
on earth, do we have to
bring them into space?
Can we start with more
Utopian ideas?
Can we talk about social
responsibility and a social license
to operate for companies in
space, as opposed to just the idea
that shareholders should
have their total return?
And as long as we obey the laws
we can do anything we want.
I don't know about you
but I really don't want
to have my employer be
in charge of my life.
Because you know that they're
not as well versed in governance
as the people who are the governors
of today; so I agree with you.
We may not be able to
solve the problems on earth
but maybe we can create environments
on mars and other places that people
on earth look up to and
say "This is a better deal,
why can't I go there"?
And if all the best and
brightest leave here to go to mars
because it's a better place,
what's going to have to
happen here on earth?
They're going to - in
order to retain the best
and brightest they're going
to have to do a better job.
So, yes thank you.
>> So I'm wondering from
the industry perspective,
have you looked or analyzed
much the [Inaudible].
>> Christopher Ketcham: The what?
>> The biosphere to
enclosure experiments.
>> Christopher Ketcham: I have not
looked at those, the biosphere -
>> Biosphere too.
>> Christopher Ketcham:
Biosphere too,
no I have not looked
at them specifically.
>> I'm curious because they do - the
biospheres were existing in models
that were somewhere
between command control,
off shore drilling platform,
[Inaudible] pioneer and yeah.
>> Christopher Ketcham: I
think we can learn from things
like the biosphere model.
They are very important
to learn from.
Dr. Steen is working right
now on Chernobyl to look
at genetic differences
from radiation.
We have that issue in mars,
unless we live in the latitudes
that may be there on mars,
we're going to be exposed
to a lot more radiation,
just like the critters
and the humans in Chernobyl.
So yes, experiments
like what you're talking
about that are self-contained
biospheres are critical.
Because what they do for us
is they tell us what kind
of biosphere do we need to
bring to another planet?
In order to sustain ourselves first,
but then the second question is
that in a few billion years from
now the sun is going to expand
and we're going to become
yesterday's barbecue.
There won't be anything
left on earth.
Now people are talking about
oh, let's come up with a plan
to move the earth out
and move it back.
Okay, I like science fiction too,
but maybe terraforming mars
is a better route to go.
But we need to know what
do we terraform mars with?
Do we want giant redwoods?
Do we bring whales?
Who has to come?
What has to come?
What needs to create a
long-term environment?
With environments - you're talking
with very small, which we're going
to be dealing with we have to
look at the lack of biodiversity.
If you have three acres of corn and
it's all genetically engineered corn
or not necessarily GMO, but
has been bread over the years
and that's all we have,
someone brings a corn musk
to that little place, they don't
have a chance, so absolutely.
We need to have those kind of
experiments on the earth today.
Yes?
>> Could I back up a little
bit, now and looking at the -
you mentioned the United Nations
and I guess you mean
the Outer space Treaty -
>> Christopher Ketcham:
The moon treaty,
there are a bunch of other treaties.
>> The space treaty talks
about with its parties
and the exclusive purposes.
The United States has interpreted
that will allow the possibility
of [Inaudible] operations out there?
Why isn't it worth
spending more time looking
at a more internationalized approach
to the use of space in terms
of international entities doing
things, like joining forces
with the space platforms now, the
international space and things
like monitoring of that military
activities here through -
what the French talked about
already in the late 70's
and international satellite
monitoring agency?
And it worked putting some
effort into that sort of thing?
>> Christopher Ketcham:
So the question is,
is it worth putting
effort into creating more
or less an international
cooperation group?
And that is one of the big questions
that I have is what should that look
like and what should that contain?
I say early on and I mean
very early on we're going
to run into space piracy.
We're going to have someone hide
behind a planet with a weapon,
a guided missile that can be
sent to this orbiter out here
to disrupt the commerce of that
particular platinum mining facility.
We are going to have
people who are going
to trash each other's satellites or
other orbiters where they're going;
so I definitely believe
that there is a need
for an international organization.
And quite frankly, let's face
it the economics and cost
of this thing are going to require a
worldwide matrix of people involved
with not only creating
the rockets to get there
but the governance issues, the laws
an international law of the sea
for space that works on that
particular kind of thing.
Near the idea of the
outer space treaty.
And dealing with issues of
problems such as the introduction
of microbes into other places.
So I agree, yes that's why I brought
up the question is the UN
the proper place for that
or are they earthly bound and we
need to look at something different
because this is a whole different,
as they say kettle of fish,
or kettle of aliens -
whatever you want to call it.
Yes?
>> We don't' have a
particularly good history
of utopian communities on earth.
They don't last long, why would
we do a better job in space?
>> Christopher Ketcham: So the
question is why would we want
to do a utopian community in space
since they haven't worked on earth?
Again, I'm not advocating for
something that is not allowed
to change as which
utopian communities are.
What I'm trying to explore with
this is the early iterations
of what we're going
to have to deal with.
If we look at a - the
original moon launch,
even the international
space station.
They are in some respects utopian
communities because they operate
in a command and control model
that says in order to be successful
in what we're doing we have to
create this kind of an environment,
which includes restrictions
on people,
etc. But what I'm saying is
there's going to be an evolution
of community out there from more
of a command, control situation
as these things get larger.
But we need to have a way of
preventing some of the kinds
of problems that we've had on earth.
What happens if there's a pull
pot on the Martian colony?
When is anyone going to be able
to get there unless
we've parked you know,
the Star Ship Enterprise
outside of Mars
to be able to take care of that?
So we have a whole different way of
looking at things it says going back
to your other questions about can
we do something better in space
than we've done on earth?
So there's kind of an equilibrium
there as far as the discussions
of what we're dealing with when we
can progress to different layers
of governance and different
forms of governance.
Maybe there are ways of once we
figure out how to terraform mars,
of actually doing a go west young
man type of approach to let people
who are coming in and
populating the areas
so that we can improve the amount
of oxygen coming from the plants
that are expected to grow there.
So there's all sorts of
opportunities for evolving.
But I think the word
justice, you know
and specifically John Rauls
definition of justice.
Justice is fairness, given the
situation and what we're talking
about and even the
laws, law of people.
What are the basic rights
of humans and animals
and even plants and other places?
We need to look at those particular
things, ask those questions
to be able to define
space communities
and they're going to be different.
You're going to have small
communities in asteroid belt.
Large communities perhaps on mars.
And perhaps some wild
thing that's headed off
to Alpha Centauri those are all
going to be different environments
and are going to require
different forms
of at least initial governance.
>> Tomoko Steen: Any
other questions?
I hope we have continuous
discussion on this topic.
Please join me thanking
today's speaker.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.